When Lucasfilm finally announced that the
title of Star Wars: Episode IX: The Rise of
Skywalker, fans wasted no time speculating
intensely about what it could mean.
Questions of who is rising, which Skywalker
the title refers to, and whether one of the
trilogy's main characters would be confirmed
as a member of the Skywalker family swirled
through the Star Wars fandom.
Fans won't get the answers to their inquiries
or have their theories validated until December
20th, but Star Wars legend Mark Hamill has
already thrown in his two cents.
Hamill, whose character Luke Skywalker seemingly
died at the end of The Last Jedi, took to
Twitter to respond to all the conjecture.
The actor absolutely loves that fans are going
wild with their Rise of Skywalker theses,
and even offered up his own ideas about who
the titular Skywalker might be.
He tweeted:
"It's time for the 8 months of speculation
to begin.
Is that Skywalker KYLO?
LEIA?
ANAKIN?
LUKE?
A previously unknown SKYWALKER?
Is REY a Skywalker?
#CoolTitle."
As soon as Hamill pressed "send" on that tweet,
he effectively opened up another floodgate
for fan theories to pour through.
Thousands of people responded to Hamill's
post, sharing predictions about how the film's
events tie into the title.
One fan theorized that the final battle of
The Rise of Skywalker will be between Rey
and Kylo Ren, with some familiar force ghosts
jumping into the fray.
Maybe Darth Vader, Anakin Skywalker, will
appear and aid Rey, thus becoming the Skywalker
who rises, according theory.
Another fan responded to that idea with a
minor revision: In a moment reminiscent of
Return of the Jedi, the ghost of Emperor Palpatine,
who is seemingly heard cackling at the end
of the Rise of Skywalker trailer, pops up
behind Kylo, while the ghost of Luke Skywalker
appears behind Rey during the duo's battle.
(laughing)
One theorist suggested that The Rise of Skywalker
isn't about Anakin Skywalker, but about Kylo
Ren, a.k.a. Ben Solo, who has Skywalker blood
thanks to his mother, Leia.
Their response to Hamill's tweet was,
"It's about Ben's redemption!
Ben is the last Skywalker!
He will rise from the dark and ask Rey out!"
Kylo Ren could drop his dark side moniker,
return to the light, and reassume his given
name of Ben Solo in The Rise of Skywalker.
That isn't too wild an idea considering he's
the only other known Skywalker apart from
the apparently fallen Luke and his mother
Leia.
He wasn't always the First Order-leading baddie
who wanted to follow in his grandfather Darth
Vader's footsteps.
"A call to the light."
One other popular theory about who the nominal
Skywalker is that it isn't a single person
at all.
Some fans believe that "Skywalker" will be
a new name for the Jedi, and that Rey will
lead them to bring peace to the galaxy.
Twitter user Dan Sandler suggested that the
Skywalker name might be included in the ancient
Jedi texts Rey took from the mystical Force
tree just before Yoda burned it down in The
Last Jedi.
The books contain all that Rey would need
to teach a new generation of Jedi.
But as Sandler speculates, there may not be
Jedi anymore.
The Skywalkers could be a combination of Jedi
and Sith.
This idea connects pretty seamlessly to the
title of the most recent Star Wars film: The
Last Jedi.
Many assumed that the title referred to Luke
Skywalker, and perhaps Luke really is the
last person in the galaxy who will be known
as a Jedi, with future Force-sensitive individuals
called Skywalkers.
For every Star Wars fan, there's a different
theory about The Rise of Skywalker.
It would be too great an undertaking to try
to pick apart every idea, but director J.J.
Abrams himself has revealed this about the
film:
"This movie is about the new generation.
What they've inherited, the light and the
dark, and ask the question about facing the
greatest evil: are they ready?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.